ما الذي تضعه AP ببساطة UAP
لا يمكن التعرف على الأجسام المحمولة جواً التي نواجهها على الفور
[موسيقى] في
الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي وخاصة أوائل الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي، كان الأمر نوعًا
من جنون الأجسام الطائرة المجهولة وكان لديك هذا النوع
من المشاهدات الجماعية للأجسام الطائرة المجهولة من
الصحون الطائرة في جميع أنحاء العالم  تبين أن الكثير من هذه الأمور في وسائل الإعلام هي
إما
مخادعون أو أشياء يمكن
شرحها بسهولة ولكن كان هناك ما يكفي من
الضجيج هناك لدرجة أن البنتاغون قرر
البدء في جمع البيانات
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
ونحن نعلم أن أعضاء خدمتنا قد
واجهوا جوًا مجهول الهوية
ونظرًا لأن الطائرات بدون طيار تشكل
خطرًا محتملاً على سلامة الطيران والأمن العام، فإننا ملتزمون ببذل
جهد مركز لتحديد أصولها